the movie revolves around a high school
boy named Rob Crabb he is extremely good
at studies but all the girls ignore him
for being a nerd and because he has
never had a girlfriend or even a
one-night stand Rob is often aroused one
morning while still in bed Rob climax is
in his pants just then his mother walks
in on him she notices his wet pants and
awkwardly tells him to throw the bed
sheet in the laundry afterwards Rob
takes a shower and gets ready for school
it's a big day for him as he is set to
appear for an admission interview for
Georgetown University Rob's father Jim
also went to the same University and
this is why he wants his son to get
admitted there before reaching School
Rob goes to his best friend's Stanley's
house Stanley is also a nerd but because
of some magical techniques he has landed
himself a hot girlfriend with whom he
has regular coitus sure you do Stanley
at school Stanley and Rob joined the
latter's childhood friend Gabrielle and
her super nerdy friend Arthur it's clear
that Gabrielle has feelings for Rob and
she invites him to hang out at her home
later that day Rob and Gabrielle have an
annual tradition of drinking beer and
watching the spelling bee oh boy Rob
accepts her invitation but he is soon
distracted by his Crush Angela suddenly
some Frat Boys show up and Bully Rob
wetting his pants with a toy water gun
however Rob soon realizes that his pants
are wet not just with water but with
something else it turns out he got
overexcited after seeing his hot Crush
Angela this couldn't come at a worse
time as Rob's all-important interview is
scheduled in an hour Gabrielle suggests
that he get a new pair of pants from the
lost and found section but Rob decides
to go with his gym shorts shortly after
as Rob along with Stanley is preparing
for his interview in the library he is
surprisingly approached by Angela she
asks him to help with her test and even
invites him over to her house later that
night Rob is stunned by the unexpected
invitation but being a loyal friend he
turns her down saying he already has
plans with Gabrielle Giga Chad boy later
in class Stanley chastises Rob for
turning down Angela's once in a lifetime
offer claiming that she was totally into
him hence he advises his best friend to
bail on Gabrielle and tutor Angela
instead later Gabrielle escorts Rob to
his interview and gives him a pep talk
assuring him that he is going to ace it
a man named Jack Roth is set to take the
interview and as soon as Rob enters the
room he apologizes for his funny shorts
Roth who is accustomed to how students
are bullied at school says it's fine I
used to bust in my pants too rob during
the interview Rob has asked about why he
wants to study at Georgetown University
instead of talking about the qualities
and the infrastructure there Rob
mentions that the only reason is because
his parents met there this moves Roth
and he breaks into tears as he also met
his late wife at Georgetown from that
point onwards the interview only goes
downhill as Roth is unable to control
his emotions after the terrible
interview Rob expresses his
disappointment with Stanley mentioning
that he is a total failure Stanley
sympathizes with him and advises him to
use Angela to lighten up his mood this
time Rob takes his advice and cancels
his plans with Gabrielle he lies that he
is not feeling well because of the
disastrous interview he had earlier Rob
then heads to Angela's place but on his
way there he meets with a small accident
however he brushes it aside and
continues his journey as soon as he
reaches Angela's home she takes him to
her bedroom and makes him sit on her bed
she then sits beside him and touches his
thighs a current runs through Rob's body
and he suddenly jerks causing her to
spill wine on her top Angela quickly
takes off her top and changes in front
of Rob much to his wonder she tells him
how much she has wanted to study with
him just then she leans in for a kiss
and places her hands on his pants
extremely turned on Rob loses
self-control and climaxes in his pants
suddenly he wakes up in his bed with wet
underwear Rob's mother again walks in on
him and tells him to change his bed
sheets Rob is confused and he can't tell
if he really experienced the other day
or or if he was merely dreaming
nevertheless he gets ready for school
and like before Rob's father gives him a
pep talk for his interview he then heads
to school where he again goes through
the same things he saw in his supposed
dreams the Frat Boys again ruin Rob's
pants forcing him to change into his gym
shorts in the library Rob tells Stanley
about his dream in which Angela wanted
to have coitus with him just then Angela
arrives and asks Rob to tutor her this
time he agrees without hesitation during
the interview Roth again breaks into
tears and Rob simply walks out instead
of comforting him afterwards he goes to
the school Clinic to find a cure for
premature climax too bad Rob there's not
one however he immediately leaves after
seeing the school nurse holding an ill
student against his wishes on his way to
Angela's home Rob realizes that he
forgot to cancel his plans with
Gabrielle however he ignores it and just
like before he meets with an accident
later he kisses Angela and once again
finishes prematurely the very next
second Rob wakes up in his bedroom and
for the second time everything that
happened the other day repeats from the
start this can fuses him but he is still
unsure if anything is merely a dream the
scene then cuts to Stanley's home where
he is in bed with his hot girlfriend
Lisa Stanley inquires why she hides her
relationship from everyone and Lisa
tells him that she can't be seen with an
unpopular guy like him their
conversation is cut short when Rob
directly barges into the bedroom to
explain the situation to Stanley however
seeing Lisa in her lingerie Rob gets
harassed and the day is reset again oh
so this is like groundhog day except
it's more like shy Hog Day Rob rushes to
school and tries to talk to Gabrielle
about his problem like clockwork the
annoying Frat Boys appear and shoot him
with the water gun but this time Rob
loses his temper and breaks the toy this
infuriates the boys and they chase him
throughout the school Rob manages to
lock himself inside a room but the bully
boys start banging on the door realizing
that he doesn't have much time left Rob
decides to use his superpower he CLI he
climb axes and resets the day his mother
walks in on him but instead of being
embarrassed Rob is glad that he man
managed to escape the bullies in the
kitchen his father Jim proceeds to give
him a lecture but this time Rob stops
him he says that he wants to do things
differently and that's why he is not
interested in going to Georgetown at
school Stanley again goes on about
having coitus with girls but Rob is no
longer interested instead he starts
lecturing about how there are greater
things in life than having coitus Rob
has now become carefree and he drives a
giant golf cart through the school's
hallway he later smokes a cigarette with
Gabrielle and the two talk about their
friendship from their conversation it's
revealed that Rob saved Gabrielle from
bullies in elementary school and ever
since then the two have been there for
each other Rob gets emotional and he
promises to Gabrielle that no matter
what they'll always keep their annual
tradition of watching the spelling bee
alive following this he appears for the
interview during which he counsels Roth
on how to cope with his wife's death Rob
then encounters his childhood bully
named Sally he decides to use his power
to reset the day to take revenge he
punches the girl in front of everyone
and consequently gets called to the
principal's office there he is informed
that Sally has called the the police and
now he's in big trouble hearing this Rob
finally panics and runs away from the
office he then approaches Stanley and
explains everything but the latter
doesn't understand any of it still he
helps Rob and takes him to the girl's
locker room however Rob is not able to
concentrate enough to pleasure himself
he walks out of the locker room dejected
and decides to turn himself in just then
he is confronted by Sally who kicks him
in the groin lo and behold the kick
arouses him and t-climaxes Rob again
wakes up in his bed and he goes to
school in a really bad mood Gabrielle
reminds him about the spelling bee
finale but Rob rudely cancels their
planned annual event Stanley senses that
his best friend is going through a bad
time and tries to cheer him up for his
interview this moves Rob and he gives
Stanley a hug after a while Angela again
asks him to come over to her place and
Rob promptly agrees he then heads for
his interview but this time Gabrielle is
not waiting for him in the hallway as a
result Rob is gloomy throughout the
interview Roth picks up on his sadness
and tells him that he is a perfect
student for Georgetown not able to hide
the truth anymore Rob goes straight to
Gabrielle's house and comes clean to her
about everything Gabrielle finds it hard
to believe but she still keeps an open
mind she tells Rob about her secret
fantasy about Abraham Lincoln that no
one knows about she then asks Rob to
tell her about his problem again after
he resets the day instructing him to use
her Abraham Lincoln secret to prove that
he's telling the truth Gabrielle then
takes Rob to the school's smartest boy
Arthur's home to seek his help however
there Arthur's superstitious grandmother
attacks him calling him a jadugar
Arthur's mother and Gabrielle come to
his rescue and put themselves between
the two unfortunately the friction
arouses Rob and he again ends up
resetting the day nothing like an angry
grandmother seal the deal Rob confronts
Arthur in school and demands to know the
meaning of jadugar Arthur hesitates from
helping him so Rob follows him to the
washroom and shoves his head in the
toilet bowl until he reveals that the
word means cursed I think it's time for
us all to admit that Rob is an [ __ ]
Rob then demands to know how to break
the curse however Arthur swears that he
has no idea how to help and Rob finally
lets him go afterwards he again explains
to Gabrielle and Stan about the infinite
Loop he is stuck in to prove himself he
tells Gabrielle about her Abraham
Lincoln secret that she told him in the
previous cycle this finally convinces
the duo that Rob is not lying after
hearing him out Stanley hypothesizes
that maybe Rob got cursed because he did
something wrong and that he must do it
correctly to break the curse at least
that's what Bill Murray did he could
become Bill finish in a hurry Rob agrees
and he thinks long and hard about what
he did wrong he comes up with the
conclusion that he didn't have proper
coitus with Angela that must be it hence
he goes to Angela's class and offers to
tutor her that evening much to the
dismay of Gabrielle in the next scene
Stan teaches Rob how to correctly please
a woman before sending him to Angela's
house the lessons seemed to work and Rob
is able to exercise more self-control
what did Stan say as the two make out
Angela tells Rob that they can have as
much coitus as they want but he must do
her homework after he returns home
hearing this Rob realizes that Angela
doesn't love him and that she is only
using him to do her homework
who cares it also Dawns on him that he
is supposed to be with Gabrielle and not
Angela outside he runs into his father
Jim who has found out that Rob skipped
his interview refusing to let Rob ruin
his life Jim takes him to the hotel
where Roth is staying they join Roth in
a restaurant and the latter asks Jim why
he is adamant on sending his son to
Georgetown Jim tells him about all the
things he gained from going to the
university however Roth replies that
maybe his son doesn't want the same
things he wanted from his life after a
while Rob is sent to fetch some drinks
and on the bar TV he sees the spelling
bee finale it suddenly Dawns on rob that
he really likes Gabrielle but he still
didn't go to her that evening and
perhaps that's why the day keeps getting
rewinded Rob returns to the table and
tells his father that he likes Gabrielle
and he doesn't want to go to Georgetown
Jim is slightly upset but he agrees to
support his son's decision following
this both Jim and Roth take Rob to
Gabrielle's home and help him climb her
window this is sus here it is revealed
that the car which kept crashing into
Rob belonged to none other than Roth
once he reaches her bedroom Roberts
explains everything to Gabrielle and
reveals that he didn't sleep with Angela
however Gabrielle is still upset with
him and asks him to leave when he
refuses she takes off her top so that he
will become aroused and reset the day
the commotion attracts the attention of
Gabrielle's father and he rushes to her
room Gabriella is embarrassed and Rob
clarifies to her father that he is not
trying to take advantage of her instead
he expresses his love for her admitting
that it took him too long to realize his
actual feelings doesn't look good for
Rob that he's doing so right after she
took off her top sadly she doesn't say a
word so a distraught Rob proceeds to
leave through the window but as soon as
Gabrielle's father closes the door and
departs she stops Rob from leaving and
the two who watch the spelling bee
together they then make out and have
coitus this time the day isn't reset and
Rob is still in bed with Gabrielle the
time Loop has been broken it turns out
the two were meant to be together and
this is why the universe kept repeating
itself until they found their way to
each other it also probably reveals that
Rob is in a simulation and the Gabrielle
is not a conscious being subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching